hey what's up everybody its Anna Mac and
welcome to a new installment or week's
best anime videos where you guys can
come and catch up on all the awesome
anime videos that you might have missed
in the past week the links to all the
videos that we mentioned are right there
in the description and if you have a
recommendation for next week just leave
it in the comments before we get started
I want to give a quick shout out to the
crazy killer clown clown lives matter
babe xxx who commented on our last video
you know on this channel bro we
definitely believe that clown lives
matter so you know please don't murder
us now this week we saw the release of
shelter a six minute anime short film
written by Porter Robinson who is an
electronic music artist shelter was
actually produced by a real anime studio
and the music was created by Porter
Robinson and Maddie on this week glass
reflection Aki dearest and giggle all
made videos praising this little short
film and ghee cook even made a video
that was actually longer than the short
itself which I thought was pretty funny
but Giga loves to talk and I love his
brand of humor so I don't mind now I
definitely recommend watching shelter
it's only six minutes of your time and
it's a hundred percent worth that it has
great visuals awesome music and it's a
good example of a collaboration between
a Western artist who is an anime fan
like Porter Robinson and a real anime
studio absolutely worth your time I've
actually been a fan of electronic music
all the way since the days of darude
sandstorm and that Punk's around the
world and I can definitely tell you that
both Porter Robinson and Madeon are
quality musical artists and I was really
happy to learn that Porter Robinson is
such a big anime fan now in case you
didn't know Daft Punk actually helped
create an hour-long anime film way back
in 2003 called
interstellar five five five five the
story of the secret star system the film
actually features music from Daft Punk's
album discovery and I just love
rewatching this film and re listening to
that album over and over again they are
both amazing if you still haven't seen
this film be sure to check it out on
Friday PewDiePie who is the biggest
youtuber ever made a video called why am
I so embarrassed in which he talks about
some of his favorite anime but
throughout the video he is really
embarrassed about the fact that he likes
anime PewDiePie seems to have the
impression that liking anime is nerdy
and embarrassing and he actually seems
to feel bad about being an
and you can definitely tell that he is
an anime fan because if you watch the
video you'll see that he's watched a lot
of anime and even read a lot of manga
now for us anime fans it's pretty weird
that someone would be so embarrassed
just for liking anime and Noble aka lost
paws actually made a video about this on
Saturday
responding to PewDiePie and asking the
question of why if PewDiePie has already
done such embarrassing things in his
previous videos is he still so
embarrassed about just liking anime I
think that a lot of this stigma about
being an anime fan comes from that whole
weeaboo meme and the fact that nowadays
everybody who likes anime even a little
bit is likely to be called a weeb or a
weeaboo online and I really I have a lot
to say about this so I think I'm gonna
upload a separate video talking about
this very issue soon probably tomorrow
so look out for that but in the meantime
definitely check out Nobles video
because he talks about some really
important issues and he raises some
excellent points in response to
PewDiePie's video WatchMojo uploaded
another top 10 list this week surprise
surprise
but actually this week they uploaded a
top 10 anime memes list in general I'm
not a huge fan of watch modules anime
lists because they tend to prioritize
those anime that are really popular in
the West at the expense of quality anime
that are not so well known here however
I did enjoy this list I thought it was
funny and if you're someone who's
immersed inside the anime community
you're gonna get the references you're
gonna find it funny so definitely check
out the video this week cook made
another video and this time it was the
fall 2016 anime abridged which is
basically a humorous and satirical look
at some of the new anime coming out in
the fall 2016 season I personally really
like a gooks brand of humor I found it
hilarious and if you're in the same boat
as me definitely look at this video
it'll make you laugh back on Monday -
anime man made a video called Japan is
not like anime and in this video he
debunks some of the myths that anime
fans from the West might have about what
Japan is really like the anime man
actually lives in Japan and he has been
living there for a while so he
definitely knows what he's talking about
on this subject although I do feel like
a lot of the stuff he says in the video
is just common sense like of course we
know that in anime social situations are
exaggerated so for example I don't think
Japanese men actually get nosebleeds
when they see an attractive woman but if
you would like to learn more about Japan
definitely give this video a watch
finally anime unity uploaded another am
we this week and this one comes from a
youtuber called nostro and it is another
visual masterpiece if you're a fan of
ambe's definitely check out this nostro
guy and be sure to subscribe to anime
unity because they feature and these
from a variety of different youtubers
every week and they never disappoint so
yeah guys that's it for this week if you
enjoyed these videos be sure to LIKE and
subscribe and we'll see you later space
cowboys